welcome to this video playing a
beautiful mind again yeah let's avoid
that sloth let's do something else not
play same stuff all the time yeah that
was recently played yeah Dwight reship
with white against vishy anand quite
that's quite interesting
like is essentially trying to play like
a queen's gambit accepted with colors
reverse but it's got the bishop out okay
which sometimes gives interesting ideas
okay go back how do you go there things
c3 and then Queen you for yeah I think
so I like I can take the bishop pair I
think I'm doing that this before a good
move to insert here or not probably not
check okay so should be three or Bishop
a 3 gives away the e4 pawn
I it's probably not much anyway Bishop
back yeah it's not much anyway let's
develop some stuff should be three and
then to see to maybe now you can go f6
probably that seems okay from black f6
and then e 5 or possibly g5
yeah I don't really want to put it there
on edge too but I don't see an
alternative trying to do f4 f4 now is
doing what if you fall probably ok don't
have to do it right away I can play
something like look you one first FYE
for is awkward maybe starting with g for
as an idea
no f 44 is really a bit awkward g4g for
you might play h5 but ok anyway
efore the SEF 54 Bishop 360 I don't
think you can take all right sorry I
don't think he can play you for and okay
yeah I take on age seven right let's
take that pawn
hmm
do I content to before maybe getting rid
of that weakness tactically if it takes
me three LG g3 okay Andrew cage aight
this Bishop before I was thinking well
okay I couldn't calculate this
completely maybe he is ok I is okay
there's also the pawn they're hanging on
c3 but maybe I can play here yep keep
that a little bit on that pressure I
wonder if f5 is a move
I have five bishop bag group h one takes
TX keep these six King III King e5 not
okay that's not leading anywhere
time warning check I don't see much that
I can do him you see simply active
enough
check
Jack graph Conda immediately that was
would have been better even nice playing
it this is really risky what is doing
here inviting me to enter
you have the chime is the problem I'm
bra offering a draw you gain dry hair we
did that before I know if he both don't
like to heck heck away on time there's
simply nothing going on and here there
is nothing going on even though I would
would lose on time him very likely at
least I mean it doesn't take long to get
to a to a totally dead position probably
book against rogue um okay and that was
complicated ranchi i was interesting for
and then f why am I felt like he I
should be really okay but maybe that
Greg wasn't the best ultimately it it
led to shine led to him getting very
active there and so this yeah this was
interesting f5 Bishop back the engine
just is this that's interesting just
kicking that house with kimchi too yeah
because here I can play this this is
actually kind of stupid for like I
understand him and share here I think
it's probably equal but what what he did
is he really invited my king up and that
is really risky check and that around
here i think i should win somehow I king
d six wins yeah okay well not much time
but this is justice justice this just
does win here Luke s7 and made now okay
I was so
very risky and again I can go I was only
seeing Bishop c6 rookie rookie I can of
course just take a seven huh ah yeah
yeah I am okay here yeah this is a draw
but not not much else not much more
let's say it's the right right way to
put it okay well thanks for watching